si vous allez suivre les recommandations
de madame me de madame montchalin c'est
à dire ne pas utiliser trop votre
climatisation à titre personnel je me
fous complètement de l'écologie ça ne
m'intéresse pas vraiment non non ça ne
m'intéresse pas moi je vois d'abord mon
intérêt et éventuellement celui de la
planète donc là ça ne m'intéresse pas je
prends des bars une fois par semaine
pour faire le dire à madame montchanin
c'est devenir le deuxième venir chez les
b sens rigoureux oui al matins
par semaine et tant pis s'il est bien il
faut arrêter
c'est quoi il faut mais j'ai pas envie
de prendre une douche moi je gère
maintenant plus de douches que des
douches et ça compensera mais bon ça
salut ça va
ça va alors après ce que tu as dit la
grosse polémique qu'est ce que vous en
pensez est ce que vous comprenez a vous
avez votés alors prenez vous le scandale
après les propos de l'avocat de ces
races à moi je vous dis la vérité
même si on n'est pas d'accord avec elle
moi j'aime j'aime son franc-parler à
sarah et quoi qu'il arrive je trouve que
déjà c'est déjà énorme et j'en ai marre
de voir des personnages en télé ils ne
disent rien ils ne servent à rien et
sarah déjà à la mène une singularité qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui on a envie de la
voir sur tous les plateaux télé qu'on
soit d'accord avec elle ou pas moi je
dis bravo à sarah voilà prêt je suis pas
forcément d'accord avec vous vous avez
dit mais j'adore le personnage voilà je
le dis j'adore le personnage et je te le
chou le dit ça qui est choqué bien
entendu ici leverdez mais il fait chier
sont
imposés c'est justement parce que je
vous apprécie énormément et que vous
êtes une avocate et mérite que je suis
choquée parce que vous ne représentez
pas que vous même une avocate elle se
dédie aux autres et je trouve que là
vous avez bradé la planète vous avez
bradé les autres en disant ça vous avez
fait preuve d'un égoïsme forcené que je
ne comprends pas de votre part vous
m'avez choqué parce qu'on avait
l'impression qu'avec votre air
dédaigneux vous vous foutez complètement
de l'écologie dont je suis choquée
travaux répondre à vos réponses elle va
dire ce qu'elle pense de toi aussi
non moi ce qui fait que vous preniez de
bain et tout ça moi je n'ai même pas le
trident donné papier tout donc chacun
fait ce qu'il peut ce qui m'a choqué
juste c'est la phrase je me fous
l'écologie vous auriez dit je prends de
bain je fais attention en un an je fais
ce que je peux je suis pas très craquant
écolo mais je me fous de l'écologie ça
en revanche aujourd'hui on peut plus
dire ça c'est impossible de dire ça
aujourd'hui quand on voit tout et
catastrophe qui a aujourd'hui on peut
pas dire je me fous l'écologie où c'est
vraiment après moi le déluge jusqu'à
quel âge on faisait ce que je pense que
ce qu'a voulu dire ça c'est que c'est
pas elle qui va changer le monde j'ai le
droit d'exprimer une opinion personnelle
j'ai exprimé mon opinion j'ai pas dis
faites comme moi j'ai le droit et vous
foutez vraiment de l'écologie non ce
n'est pas dans mes priorités c'est ce
que j'ai dit ça y est j'ai des combats
les personnes âgées les femmes victimes
de violences conjugales la cause animale
je ne suis pas peut-être pas une
ayatollah de l'écologie effectivement
avec deux heures mais d'accord mais là
on va contextualiser la ministre avait
dit j'invite tout le monde à baisser la
clim mais déjà que le gouvernement
applique à lui-même les consignes on a
baissé la clim à l'elysée dans ce cas là
donc répond à question provocatrice
réponse provocatrice
oublier les choses aussi baisse la clim
dans ce cas là on vient voter en jet
privé et ont dit oui et c'est là qu'on
m'a donc j'aimerais qu'il ya un devoir
d'exemplarité et qu'ensuite on vient de
donner des leçons on a des entreprises
qui payent des agences de com pour
montrer qu'elles sont écolos derrière
elles n'en n'ont rien à faire à la folie
et moi on vient me cyber harceler parce
que il se trouve que je suis assez
solide pour l'encaisser ok comment mais
hugot clément quand il met ça pour faire
son de cette province est un ami mais ça
peut être un ami mais c'est moi c'est
quelqu'un que mais maintenant c'est pas
un argument de dire parce que d'autres
font mal les choses bah moi je les fais
mal aussi jeune
parce qu'elle vit aussi c'est que un
discours de culpabilisation et
d'intimidation les individus alors que à
l'ehess que l'écologie c'est évidemment
toi et moi mais c'est aussi et surtout
ceux qui polluent et évidemment c'est
les entreprises du cac 40 c est ce que
c'est ça qu'est née ma priorité est
donnée aux habitants les groupes la
raison de votre priorité à mykonos et
quoi
l'écologie
génération on dit ça qu'aujourd'hui on
est dans ebuya le côté je m'en fous
personnes en quarante ans je serai mort
pendant quarante ans
[Rires]
il faut penser un petit peu delphine
capelle
alors moi j'ai une question parce que de
but en blanc quand je vois ça je trouve
ça super d'avoir les avis tranchés mais
là ce que vous avez dit sur ces images
ça ne sert à rien à part provoqué ça ne
sert à rien d'accord mais on en parle
quand même donc manifestement ça sert
pas à rien ça élève le débat parce qu'on
se rend compte que l'écologie finalement
qu'est ce que c'est aujourd'hui qu'on
peut dire que ça ne sert à rien je
trouve que c'est un peu réducteur c'est
bien donc c'est bien si vous avez fait
ça vraiment en pensant que ça allait lui
et élever le débat mais ce que c'est
vraiment ça que vous pensez à ce moment
là quand vous avez dit ça alors là c'est
mon nom en foot indoor ce moment là
c'est une réponse à la ministre qui à
mon sens pose une question provocatrice
à question provocatrice réponse qu'on
vaut quatre mois quand je dis je ne sais
pas si c'était dans l'extrême moi aussi
elle me fait penser je vais acheter ma
clim c'est vous pouvez vraiment demain
par jour oui tiens vous claquez 150
litres d'eau par jour à vous tout seul
mais c'est plus que sensations comme
vous voulez vous voilez l'avion ça
serait très peu moi aussi très peu oui
donc ça veut dire dans l'avion mais ce
que je veux c'est que maintenant son
idée
écologique que j'ai je n'en ai pas je ne
connais pas mais je vous le dis vous
avez oublié qu'il ya un animateur cette
émission
non mais c'est qu'on est toujours en
train de culpabiliser les jets losc est
plus important
sur posture et béatrice et géraldine
mais je veux je ne sens pas parfaitement
mon petit péché mignon c'est les bains
mais j'essaye de faire d'autres choses
marais - srna puis parce
qu'effectivement vous êtes un homme dans
un truc qui s'appelle des grandes
gueules
aussi je les adore et je les embrasse
font une émission et j'attire
l'attention là dessus on a encore une
liberté directement
quand on est chez toi il ya une liberté
d'expression adore les grandes gueules
aussi moi je leur dis mais libre ne veut
pas dire dire n'importe quoi
dit la même chose ici tu pas d'accord là
tu dis mais l'on connaît la corse non
ici on dit ce qu'on veut c'est pareil
dans les hôtels c'est pour ça que sont
ces grandes qui t'écoutent les grands il
sait qu'il va passer sinon s'il faut
toucher si le sens je fais chier
antennes et en radio voilà sa déception
valable du paf les grandes gueules cyril
si j'ai passé à orthez des personnes ce
n'était pas le but du d'accord cette
histoire c'est toujours la même chose il
ya des appels à la santé la censure
maintenant on ne peut plus avoir de
d'idées qui ne soit pas dans le
consensus mainstream et au delà de ce
cas particulier je suis pas forcément
d'accord on s'en fout pas c'est une
question d'éducation on élève ses
enfants à ne pas gâcher on élève ses
enfants à être en accord avec la nature
voilà déjà si les gens faisaient ça et
là peut-être dire écologie va pas faire
deux jours sur l'économie
qui sont choqués la plupart sont des
hypocrites ils ont le dernier
vrai dire je voudrais dire à tous moi
avec tout ce qui se passe actuellement
je pense qu'il ya quand même un vrai
problème la planète j'en parle souvent
avec hugo clément d'ailleurs et c'est
vrai que voilà ça doit quand même une
priorité mais la seule question que je
pose à chaque fois judy à l'échelle de
notre échelle en france on est un tout
petit pays pour cent les mecs ont on ne
sert à rien on peut faire tout ce qu'on
veut on changera pas le sort de la
planète je vous le dis donc voilà donc
merci c'est la censure et le droit de
dire ce que
c'est son ciel a cessé la maco